le maire de montfermeil fait une rechute
souvenez vous il avait déjà fait
beaucoup parler de lui c'était en
octobre dernier il s'opposer à
l'inscription de nouveaux enfants
immigrés dans les écoles de sa ville
sous prétexte qu'il y avait déjà trop
d'étrangers il recommence et ils coupent
les vivres deux écoles primaires
chantal kimmerlin ses enfants ont évité
le pire sans le savoir vivre à l'école
toute une journée sans manger et dans
des locaux jamais nettoyé prétexte de
leur maire pierre bernard ils sont
immigrées et trop nombreux inscrits
d'office à l'école par la préfecture du
département de la seine saint denis
ces enfants connaîtront leur salut
scolaire grâce à cette même préfecture
dès lundi l'état se substitue à la
mairie de montfermeil pour assurer la
cantine et le gardiennage des enfants il
paiera ainsi les frais d'un autre
traiteur et du personnel de service
mais la note sera finalement imputée sur
le budget de la mairie en relançant
cette affaire le maire de montfermeil
veut déclencher un nouveau débat sur la
difficulté d'intégrer jusqu'à 95 %
d'enfants immigrés dans certaines écoles
condamnation de la vie